Yeah,
we're looking for answers
and I can pick that
collection of dark web.
I think that,
I mean,
you get that when you listen to broken
[inaudible] broken a lot for me.
That's the first thing he said.
Touch God.
You can trust them.
He's,
he's not self rammed down and head.
He's not narcissistic of,
even though he spectacularly successful,
he keeps his feet on the ground.
He doesn't inflate himself,
he doesn't make claims
about his whole life.
Um,
the extent of his knowledge,
he's very aware of when it doesn't know
that there's a real confidence in that.
Right.
Joe knows there's a whole bunch
of things he doesn't know.
He keeps inviting people onto the show
and those things he doesn't know and he
doesn't care that he doesn't know that
he's happy to talk to people who know
some things he doesn't know.
And that's real ways to brightness,
to be confident and [inaudible].
So there's this,
there's this quest and Samsung
request and he's also courageous.
You know,
like he takes on heart issues
and he doesn't back down.
And sometimes that's just
persistent stubbornness.
Let's say one,
well,
you know,
Tony used to do two separate persistence
from stupidity sometimes mean,
and I remember surfing.
I'm seeing that here is
oversight of stupidity,
but,
but it's hard to,
it's hard to separate those things,
but he's very adamant in his pursuit of
truth and he's willing to go places that
are dangerous and then
hard on his reputation.
So more power to them
as far as I'm concerned.
[inaudible].